and then I was thinking that next week
we could go to the zoo wouldn't that be
fun color what the hell are you doing uh
I just I'm having some alone time with
the we uh yeah about that we've been
getting a lot of complaints the way you
only cover the we you know they're free
consoles on the market got the new
playstation 3 controller in maybe we
could do something on that I yeah but I
mean the people who make a line writer
are coming in today line writer and
they're going to show us the wii version
can't we do it ayan writers cool but you
got to balance it out uh okay look how
about a review Viking battle for asgard
it's on playstation 3 and 360 so it's
like a now it's like a twofer i guess
that works I tell you what I'm gonna
leave this door open so we can see what
you're doing in here okay no they'll
never take you away from me don't worry
okay so today we've got Chris Keenan of
in exile entertainment there the
publishers of lying writer too unbound
which is coming out on the pc the wii
and the DF yep you're the producer of
the game yep and so you were going to
tell us all about it it's physics based
and what you do is you draw the
environment around a little virtual
sledder and so as opposed to most games
where you control the actual main
character we do here is you modify the
environment you press play and this
letter will go down which physics based
upon what the environment is so you can
get him doing loop-de-loops can get him
riding on the nose and flipping around
and it is something that you know the
younger crowd be not quite so artistic
crowd like me you can go through and
just play and have fun there on the sled
around get them doing tricks and the
people that are a little more artistic
and make these amazing creations with it
basics what we wanted is we want to make
sure that we added on to the splash
version and we want to make sure that we
added more tools more line types new
features associated with that we also
wanted to create a game around it so we
added the story mode we added a puzzle
mode to it and so the Freestyle is all
the core elements that you have from the
original line rider with these extra
tools and then as you go into story mode
we've added as you can see behind us
here we've had a green region boxes and
so basically have a starting point in
the finished point and you've got to be
you've got to draw inside those region
boxes and figure out how you're going to
get the guy from the start point to the
finish unharmed they want to make sure
that that people would be able to make
very impressive tracks because as you
see what the flash version there's a
pretty big difference between you know
some someone that's maybe not quite as
talented artistically and somebody like
tech dog who guys see the news making
out the dogs on transcendental and all
these huge you know triumphant tracks
and so we want to make sure that that
you know these young players and people
like it could go through there and we've
been fitted clipart think go and stamp
into the game as well we've done things
with different layers and backgrounds
and so you can draw things in a
background it's going to scroll at a
slower rate as well things on the
foreground that the rider coat and pass
behind so this creates a 3d effect using
parallax so you'll be able to see the
tracks look like they're in a lot of 3d
similar to the way that like an old
Mario Brothers game we do it all right
uh well I'm
very excited to play this is coming out
in this summer yes so okay so at some
point in the summer will be able to play
line right or to unbound PC we r EDS
thank you very much for us for being
here on today's video game review
segment I'd like to talk to you guys
about what makes a video game addictive
now some games are addictive because of
the story you really want to find out
what happens next summer addictive
because of the way the gameplay ramps up
just so and you've got to keep yourself
going to the next challenge and the next
one and the next one then some games are
addictive because I don't know just
because they're addictive just like
Viking battle for asgard available now
for Xbox 360 and PlayStation 3 biking is
from Creative Assembly and Sega the team
that brought you Spartan total warrior
biking leaves ancient Greece behind and
drops you into ancient Norse mythology
as scarin a warrior brought back to life
by the goddess Freya you've got to
liberate the island of Midgard from
hell's demons yes I realized this is not
exactly newly fallen snow we're trotting
on here but the story isn't important in
fact it's not really told very well then
the few cinema scenes are forgettable
but that's just less BS to get in the
way of the action as scarring you'll
single-handedly take back your kingdom
from the evil blue guys hacking them to
bits with your sword and axe combat is
ok it's not god of war but finishing off
an indigo demon with a big well-timed
sword slice that hacks off his head and
arms all at once what could be happier
the game's got a Grand Theft Auto style
open world although your only
transportation is your own two feet
you'll run from farm to quarry to
distillery liberating key military posts
and rescuing your fellow kidnapped
loincloth barbarians now you can't just
walk into these occupied territories
you'll get killed what you've got to do
is sneak around the perimeter knocking
off guards and archers one by one
thinning out their ranks yes the giant
lumbering scar and has all the stealth
ability of a pregnant rhinoceros but to
balance that out your enemies have the
intelligence of half a
tato chip so it works so why is it so
addictive it's the carrot-and-stick
approach to game design Viking
constantly dangles just one more little
easily accomplished goal in front of
your face hey why don't you liberate
this town why don't you rescue these
soldiers one more level one more level
it works because there's no loading time
the whole map loads when you turn the
game on that's it and because of the
aforementioned lack of cinema scenes and
BS all the fluff is stripped away then
you're left with gameplay that keeps you
up until three in the morning once
you've liberated enough towns you'll
join together with literally a thousand
other warriors and siege and enemy's
stronghold this is really impressive
stuff watching countless Warriors and
mages battle it out but the action slows
to a crawl during these scenes I guess
it's too much for 360 and ps3 to handle
Viking doesn't do any one thing
particularly well the story is silly the
combat is merely okay and the graphics
are basically borderline but because
it's designers understand how to keep a
player hooked it's actually a lot more
fun than some games that might be more
polished in other areas um you know I
think that's a lesson that a lot of game
designers should take to heart and
that's why we give Viking battle for
asgard a Valhalla approved 7 out of 10
you